Sometimes it might not be clear to what exactly does this
particular verb correspond to. So consider,
Susan comforted Jing. Well, what exactly did Susan do to comfort Jing?
It's not at all clear. Not clear what the primitive action should be.
Although if you may not understand what exactly is the primitive action here.
We want agents nevertheless to do common sense reasoning.
Their interpretation might be incomplete, this interpretation might be partial.
Nevertheless, you and I, as humans understand something about Susan and
Jing here, that Susan for example, did something that made Jing happier.
We want the agent to do the same kind of reasoning, without knowing what exactly
is the comforting action here. So we may have a generic primitive action of do.
This generic primitive action will use it, whenever we are unable to decide,
whenever the agent is unable to decide, what exactly is the primitive action
that should be pulled out. So the agent will simply say, well, Susan did
something that made Jing's mood happy and this is as much interpretation that
the agent might be able to the sentence, which is a pretty good interpretation.